well we've just got some news in now and
the number of deaths from in the UK
excuse me from the coronavirus has risen
to eleven thousand three hundred and
twenty nine that's up from ten thousand
six hundred and twelve let's go back to
and ashes Joshi in the newsroom just
bring us up to date oh yes we've got a
breakdown from the Department for Health
and Social Care this is the UK total and
again we have the four nation's
reporting their figures that total will
not add up to the total presented in
this reporting period by the Department
of Health and Social Care and that's
because of the way the data is collected
and processed and then reported let me
give you their breakdown sadly another
717 people reported to have lost their
lives across the UK a total number of
tests carried out fourteen thousand five
hundred and six total number of people
tested ten thousand seven hundred and
forty five and of those four thousand
three hundred and forty two were tested
positive the total number of people have
died of covert 19 here in the UK now
stands at eleven thousand three hundred
and twenty nine so the same cabinet as
we've been reporting throughout today
bank holiday weekend that there is a lag
in the system there were no published
figures available over the weekend in
some areas they are shut so it takes
time for those numbers to be collected
and sent through for central processing
and that's one of the reasons and also
we have to remember that the the deaths
reported are the deaths in hospitals
certainly for England we've heard the
First Minister in Scotland talking about
the Office for National Statistics
talking about deaths in care homes those
are not reflected in these figures so
this is the figure that stands at the
moment that people will look at that and
say and try and make some sense of it
when they plot those numbers on a graph
this can't be taken on its own as a
snapshot and you can't read too much
into that figure as it stands but
there because of the bank holiday
weekend and also because we've seen in
the past Kimberly we've seen when we've
reported for this on a Monday although
it shows that that the numbers are
declining then suddenly by Tuesday
Wednesday
they grow against